- [Voiceover] Fireworks are
associated with celebration,
but they originally stem from
a place of fear and folklore.
In 200 BC, some people in China believed
that a tribe of scary
Bigfoot-esque mountain men
lurked in the foothills.
And the most logical way
to ward off this enemy?
Scare ‘em.
They realized that heating bamboo shoots
caused air pockets in the plant to burst,
creating a loud popping noise
which they thought would
keep the mountain men away.
And it allegedly worked!
800 years later, Chinese muggles set out
on a quest for immortality,
and while they didn't
find the elixir of life,
these alchemists ended up creating
the world's first batch of gunpowder.
Funny how the desire to live forever
was essentially a gateway
drug to modern warfare.
But, anyway, back to the story.
They took this new fire
drug, as they called it,
stuffed it into their
bamboo shoots, and kaboom!
Fireworks were born.
Excitement over the invention of gunpowder
and fiery sticks eventually
made its way around the world.
Fast forward to July
3rd, 1776, the day before
the Declaration of
Independence was signed.
John Adams wrote a letter to his wife
with big plans for commemorating the day.
- [Voiceover] It ought to be solemnized
with pomp and parade...
bonfires and illuminations
from this time forward forevermore.
- [Voiceover] Adams wanted
illuminations, he got em.
The sky lit up with fireworks on July 4th,
and from that day forward fireworks
have become a ubiquitous
American celebratory tradition.
So I guess the next time
you see the sky ablaze,
you can thank Bigfoot.
I mean, the Chinese.
Or John Adams.
Your call.
(patriotic music playing)